(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre a desocupação
de um imóvel em leilão extrajudicial.
Como a gente já falou anteriormente aqui no
curso, no leilão extrajudicial não existe um processo
judicial prévio.
O credor fiduciário não deve recorrer ao Poder
Judiciário para levar ou não um imóvel a
leilão.
Ele pode fazer isso automaticamente, bastando que ele
faça a consolidação da propriedade em seu nome.
Por que ele pode fazer isso sem precisar
do Poder Judiciário?
Porque foi assim que a lei estipulou, a
lei 9.514, falou que o credor fiduciário
pode ter essa facilidade.
Isso é uma forma de convite para que
instituições financeiras celebrem contratos de alienação fiduciária, porque
vai ser muito mais fácil, não vai precisar
do Poder Judiciário.
Então o credor, basta que o devedor atrase
o pagamento, o credor consolide a propriedade em
seu nome e o leilão vai ser realizado,
como a gente já estudou em todas essas
aulas do módulo 2.
Existem alguns poucos casos em que o credor
fiduciário, antes da realização do leilão, ele já
entra com uma ação para desocupação do imóvel.
Essa ação de desocupação do imóvel é chamada
de ação de emissão na posse.
Se você pegar um caso de um leilão
em que o credor tenha feito isso, você
vai ter que se subrogar no lugar do
credor naquela ação judicial que já existe.
O que significa se subrogar no local do
credor?
Nada mais é do que você vai substituir
o credor naquele pólo ativo daquela ação.
Toda ação judicial tem um pólo ativo, que
é o autor do processo, e um pólo
passivo, que é o réu daquele processo.
Então, caso o credor fiduciário tenha entrado com
uma ação de emissão da posse antes da
realização do leilão, ele vai ser o autor
daquele processo, ele vai estar no pólo ativo
daquele processo.
O arrematante, uma vez finalizado o leilão, ele
vai substituir o credor naquele pólo ativo, ele
vai ser o novo autor daquele processo.
Por quê?
Porque ele vai ser o novo proprietário daquele
bem.
O credor, o antigo credor, o banco, na
maioria dos casos, ele não vai ter mais
relação com aquele imóvel, ele vendeu aquele imóvel
em leilão, ele some daquela relação daquele imóvel,
quem vai existir no novo lugar é o
arrematante.
Só que esses casos são bem excepcionais realmente,
geralmente os bancos não entram com esse processo
de emissão na posse previamente, eles deixam que
o arrematante faça esse processo depois da arrematação
de um imóvel.
Então, você arrematou um imóvel em leilão escrajudicial,
não existe um processo prévio para que aquele
imóvel fosse em um leilão escrajudicial, o banco,
ele não ajuizou uma ação de emissão na
posse para tirar aquela pessoa enquanto o leilão
estava sendo realizado, então você arrematante vai ter
que fazer esse processo de desocupação.
Você vai ter que recorrer a uma ação
de emissão na posse, mas você vai recorrer
a essa ação de emissão na posse no
poder judiciário de cara?
Não.
Você, antes de mais nada, deve tentar um
acordo com o ocupante do imóvel.
Como é que você vai tentar um acordo
com o ocupante do imóvel?
Você vai mandar uma forma de notificação para
esse ocupante, e nessa forma de notificação você
deve deixar bem claro os seus dados, como
é que ele pode entrar em contato com
você, falar que você é um novo proprietário
daquele bem e que você tem interesse em
um acordo para realizar aquela desocupação.
Qual é a vantagem desse acordo?
Muitas vantagens.
Primeiro, você não vai ter que recorrer ao
poder judiciário, você não vai ter que pagar
um advogado para isso, você já vai baratear
o seu custo.
Em segundo lugar, que a desocupação quando acontece
por um acordo, ela é bem mais rápida
do que uma desocupação quando ela acontece pelo
poder judiciário.
Você pode mandar essa notificação para o ocupante,
para o devedor daquela relação e oferecer um
prazo de um mês para ele sair, dois
meses para ele sair.
Aqui cabe até você oferecer alguma vantagem pecuniária
para aquele devedor.
Você pode oferecer, por exemplo, que você vai
pagar a mudança dele para onde ele queira
ir, que você pode pagar o primeiro aluguel
dele em algum lugar.
Isso, obviamente, vai depender de valores e você
vai estipular esse valor do acordo que você
quer fazer.
E qual é a vantagem de realizar esse
acordo mesmo que você estipule um valor?
Pode ser que aquele valor que você ia
pagar para um advogado, você escolha acordar alguma
coisa com o ocupante para que ele possa
sair de uma maneira mais rápida.
Então, vamos supor, você iria pagar para um
advogado 3 mil reais para entrar com essa
ação, você pode chegar no ocupante e falar,
olha, eu pago só a mudança e o
seu primeiro aluguel.
Se for um aluguel mais básico, você não
vai fazer isso para o cara morar num
aluguel de 10 mil reais por mês, você
vai fazer isso num apartamento mais básico que
ele tem interesse em morar.
Então, se esse aluguel de um apartamento for,
por exemplo, 1.500 reais e a mudança
dos móveis dele custar 2 mil reais, vale
a pena que você faça uma proposta de
acordo, inclusive oferecendo essa vantagem de pagar a
mudança dele, de pagar o primeiro aluguel, porque
esse seria o valor que você pagaria para
o advogado.
Então, você pode fazer essa proposta para o
ocupante e o ocupante pode sair desse imóvel
de maneira muito mais rápida.
No geral, as pessoas que perdem imóveis em
leilão excrujudicial, elas sabem que elas estão perdendo
aquele imóvel.
A pessoa, quando ela assina um contrato de
alienação fiduciária, ela sabe que se ela não
pagar o número X de parcelas que ficou
expulado naquele contrato, ela vai perder aquele imóvel.
As pessoas chamam isso popularmente do banco retomou
o meu imóvel, mas o banco não retomou
o seu imóvel.
O banco recebeu o imóvel como garantia, esse
imóvel foi dado como garantia pelo próprio devedor.
Então, o próprio devedor, na hora que ele
contou com o financiamento do banco, ele transferiu
a propriedade para o banco.
É a chamada transferência da propriedade resolúvel.
Então, ele sabe que se ele deixar de
pagar três parcelas, se assim foi estipulado no
contrato dele, o banco vai retomar a propriedade,
vai botar o imóvel em leilão.
Então, quando o imóvel de devedor vai a
leilão antiprejudicial, na maioria dos casos, esse devedor
não vai se opor à desocupação do bem.
Como eu já falei antes aqui no curso,
existem muitos casos em que vai constar a
informação de que o imóvel está ocupado, mas
o devedor já até saiu do imóvel para
não ter que passar por um processo de
desocupação, que pode ser um processo muito traumático.
Se tiver que recorrer à justiça, se tiver
que fazer uma desocupação forçada com o auxílio
de força policial, isso tudo é muito traumático
para as pessoas.
As pessoas tendem ao máximo a evitar que
isso chegue.
Então, pode ser que você se depare com
uma informação de que o imóvel está ocupado
e o devedor já desocupou aquele imóvel porque
ele sabe que aquele imóvel está indo à
leilão e ele não quer passar por esse
processo de ser retirado do seu imóvel e
pode ser que você tenha grande chance de
êxito de fazer um acordo de desocupação com
aquele ocupante para que você não tenha que
recorrer ao Poder Judiciário.
E aí vai ficar ao seu critério como
é que você quer estipular ou não esse
acordo.
Você pode só dar um prazo para essa
pessoa, você pode dar um prazo e oferecer
algo também para essa pessoa, como pagamento de
uma mudança, como pagamento de um primeiro aluguel,
vai ficar a seu critério.
Quando você deve fazer a notificação para um
acordo com essa pessoa?
Você não deve fazer a notificação para o
acordo logo após você arrematar o imóvel à
leilão.
Isso porque, vamos supor que você arremate o
imóvel e cinco dias depois seja feita a
escritura daquele imóvel.
A escritura pública de compra e venda, como
a gente já falou na aula anterior, é
o documento que você vai levar ao cartório
de registro de imóveis para passar o imóvel
para o seu nome.
Então mesmo que você tenha essa escritura rapidamente
na sua mão, quando você dá a entrada
num cartório para que o cartório realize o
registro dessa escritura, os cartórios costumam levar em
média 30 dias para finalizar esse registro.
E só a partir do registro você é
legítimo proprietário.
Eu falei na aula anterior que, para a
nossa lei, só é proprietário quem registra o
imóvel.
Então você só é definitivamente proprietário daquele imóvel
a partir do momento que você registra.
Você só poderia entrar com uma ação de
emissão na posse, caso você tenha que recorrer
ao judiciário, comprovando que você tem um título
de propriedade.
Qual é o título de propriedade?
É o registro daquele imóvel em seu nome.
Você vai pegar a matrícula e vai constar
o registro em seu nome e aquele é
o seu título de propriedade.
Então você deve mandar essa notificação depois que
você der a entrada no cartório para registrar
a propriedade em seu nome.
Mas você vai esperar os 30 dias do
cartório para mandar a notificação?
Não.
Você pode dar a entrada, esperar passar um
prazo de 10 dias e enviar a notificação.
Isso porque nesse prazo que você vai conceder
para a pessoa sair do imóvel, ou até
mesmo num prazo em que vocês vão abrir
tratativas para chegar a um acordo que os
dois concordem, para que você não tenha que
recorrer ao poder judiciário, pode ser que leve
um tempo.
E nesse tempo que você vai estar discutindo
uma proposta de acordo, ou até mesmo que
a pessoa já aceitou o acordo, mas é
o tempo que ela tem para sair do
imóvel, o cartório vai finalizar o seu registro
e aí tudo certo.
Aqui nessa aula eu vou deixar um modelo
de como fazer essa notificação para um acordo
para desocupação.
Outro ponto muito importante é que você deve
mandar essa notificação com aviso de recebimento.
Você deve ter como provar que você propôs
ao ocupante, ao devedor fiduciário, que você propôs
esse acordo.
Como é que você vai fazer isso?
Uma forma muito simples é você mandar esse
acordo através de um telegrama, porque no telegrama
os correios vão mandar uma cópia desse telegrama
para a pessoa e depois que a pessoa
receber o telegrama, você vai receber também uma
cópia.
Também existe uma outra saída que é você
mandar uma carta com aviso de recebimento, porque
você vai mandar essa carta com aviso de
recebimento, o aviso de recebimento vai ser assinado
pela pessoa que recebeu aquele aviso, assinado e
datado, e esse aviso de recebimento vai voltar
para você.
Se esse imóvel que você arrematou for um
condomínio, quem vai assinar esse aviso de recebimento
é o porteiro daquele prédio e não tem
problema nenhum quanto a isso, basta que você
tenha um comprovante de que você notificou essa
pessoa.
Então você vai botar nessa notificação todos os
seus dados e pedir para que a pessoa
entre em contato com você.
Se a pessoa não entrar em contato com
você, você vai saber que ela recebeu aquela
notificação porque você vai receber o aviso de
recebimento ou se for no telegrama também vai
constar a data em que a pessoa recebeu.
Você pode recorrer àquele site que a gente
falou no módulo 1, o consulte fácil, e
buscar através do CPF daquela pessoa os dados
dela.
Como a gente falou no módulo 1, esse
consulte fácil ele apresenta também o telefone da
pessoa, então você pode entrar diretamente em contato
com essa pessoa, ou se você tiver o
e-mail dessa pessoa, você pode mandar o
e-mail com o aviso de recebimento também
para essa pessoa, tudo para comprovar que você
teve.
Realizado um acordo, e se nesse acordo você
estipulou que você vai pagar alguma coisa para
aquela pessoa, seja o primeiro aluguel, seja o
valor da mudança, você deixa para pagar somente
na hora que aquele acordo estiver sendo cumprido.
Então vamos supor, você arrematou o imóvel, mandou
a notificação para o morador, o morador aceitou
entrar em um acordo com você, ficou estipulado
que ele vai desocupar o apartamento e até
quinta diz que você vai pagar a mudança
daquela pessoa.
Deixa para pagar a mudança daquela pessoa somente
no momento que aquela mudança da pessoa estiver
saindo.
Então no dia que ficou combinado para devolução
do imóvel, ou seja, para desocupação daquele imóvel,
compareça, ou faça comparecer através de uma pessoa
que você enviar, essa pessoa vai receber as
chaves daquele imóvel e vai pagar a quantia
que ficou estipulada.
Não pague nada anteriormente, porque pode ser que
você pague e a pessoa desista de sair
daquele acordo, e você vai ter que recorrer
ao Poder Judiciário para depois tentar também rever
aquele dinheiro que você pagou.
Então deixa para pagar somente no momento que
você tem a certeza que o acordo vai
ser respeitado.
Agora, existem alguns casos em que você vai
propor esse acordo e a pessoa não vai
aceitar esse acordo, vai falar que só vai
sair quando tiver realmente uma ordem da justiça
para que ela saia.
Nesses casos vai ser necessário que você entre
com uma ação de emissão na posse.
Essa ação de emissão na posse, ela necessariamente
vai ter que ser feita por um advogado.
Mas eu vou deixar um modelo aqui nessa
aula também de uma petição inicial de uma
ação de emissão na posse.
Isso porque você basicamente vai ter que preencher
os dados específicos da arrematação que você fez,
o seu nome completo, identidade, CPF, vai botar
os dados do imóvel que você arrematou, o
dia que você arrematou, por quanto você arrematou,
e vai levar para um advogado.
O advogado vai ter um trabalho muito mais
simplificado se você fizer isso, porque ele só
vai ter o trabalho de revisar aquela peça
e protocolar.
Então eu acredito fielmente que disponibilizando esse modelo
para vocês de ação de emissão na posse,
vocês podem reduzir bastante os custos desse advogado.
Você levando o trabalho dele quase pronto, não
faz sentido que ele te cobre o mesmo
do que se ele tivesse que fazer a
petição inicial ou desde o começo.
Então é uma forma de tentar ajudar para
que vocês reduzam esses gastos.
Como é que funciona essa emissão na posse?
A própria lei 9.514, que é a
que regula a aliança financeira, que é a
que fala sobre o leilão escrajudicial, ela também
fala da ação de emissão na posse.
E ela estipula que o juiz deve receber
essa ação de emissão na posse, e essa
ação de emissão na posse vai ter um
pedido liminar, o juiz deve deferir esse pedido
liminar e conceder um prazo de até 60
dias para que a pessoa desocupe o imóvel.
Então vamos explicar o que significa tudo isso.
Pedido liminar.
Quando existe um pedido liminar no processo, você
está pedindo para aquele juiz, para que ele
antecipe o que ele iria conceder no final
daquele processo.
Então você tem toda a documentação que te
protege e que aquele processo deveria ao final
dele ser procedente, que você deveria ganhar aquele
processo.
Você pede um pedido liminar para que o
juiz antecipe o resultado daquele processo.
Você vai provar que você tem direito ao
que você teria ao final e o juiz
vai dar esse resultado logo de pronto quando
você entrar com o processo.
Isso acontece na ação de emissão na posse
e a própria lei diz que isso deve
acontecer.
O juiz, uma vez recebendo essa ação de
emissão na posse com o pedido liminar, ele
deve conceder a liminar, ou seja, ele vai
antecipar os efeitos que aquele processo teria ao
final para que esses efeitos sejam cumpridos logo
no início do processo.
Então o juiz vai deferir a liminar, vai
concordar com a liminar e vai conceder um
prazo de até 60 dias para que o
ocupante saia do imóvel.
O ocupante vai ser notificado judicialmente, ele vai
ser intimado, é a palavra correta, para que
ele desocupe aquele imóvel.
E se o ocupante não sair daquele imóvel
em 60 dias?
Nesse caso, o juiz vai determinar que a
desocupação seja feita por um oficial de justiça
e poderá inclusive ser uma desocupação forçada.
O que significa que pode ser uma desocupação
forçada?
Pode ser que se o oficial de justiça
chegar lá e o ocupante não abrir a
porta da casa, pode ser que tenha uma
ordem de arrombamento.
Então vai arrombar esse imóvel.
Como é que vai arrombar esse imóvel?
O arrematante deve disponibilizar um chaveiro para a
hora que o oficial de justiça chega lá,
o chaveiro, ele vai abrir aquela porta e
você já aproveita e pede para o chaveiro
mudar o miolo daquela fechadura para garantir que
só você a partir daquele momento vai ter
a chave daquele imóvel e também pode ter
desocupação forçada.
Se tiver os bens móveis desse ocupante dentro
do imóvel, pode tirar todos esses bens à
força e para isso o arrematante também deve
colocar à disposição do juiz um caminhão de
mudança.
Então por isso que às vezes você entrar
em um acordo e você pagar a mudança,
no final das contas vai ser muito mais
vantajoso para você, porque caso ocorra uma desocupação
forçada num processo judicial, numa ação de missão
na posse, você pode ser que você tenha
que pagar esse caminhão de mudança se chegar
lá na hora, se o oficial de justiça
chegar lá no dia e o ocupante realmente
não tiver saído, vai ter que tirar todos
aqueles bens do ocupante dentro do imóvel e
você vai ter que pagar um caminhão de
mudança.
Então você pode antecipar esse seu custo de
pagar um caminhão de mudança e se livrar
do custo de um advogado para a inclinação
de missão na posse.
Realizar um acordo oferecendo mudança, oferecendo às vezes
o primeiro aluguel de uma pessoa é muito
vantajoso.
Pode ser que você realize um acordo somente
oferecendo um prazo, isso aí vai ficar seu
critério, como a gente já falou antes.
Então dito isso, vamos só recapitular.
Caso você não consiga um acordo para uma
desocupação, você necessariamente vai ter que entrar com
uma ação de missão na posse, essa ação
de missão na posse vai ter que ser
feita por um advogado, tem um modelo aqui
para que vocês levem esse modelo pronto e
o advogado possa cobrar menos de vocês.
Esse advogado vai dar a entrada naquela petição,
o juiz ele deve conceder a liminar e
oferecer um prazo de até 60 dias para
o ocupante sair do imóvel.
Se o ocupante não sair do imóvel, esse
pedido de desocupação vai ser cumprido por um
oficial de justiça.
Esse oficial de justiça ele vai comparecer lá
no dia e se o ocupante ainda assim
se recusar a sair daquele imóvel, ele vai
realizar a desocupação forçada.
Essa desocupação forçada pode inclusive contar com arrombamento
de porta e retirar a força dos objetos
que estão lá dentro.
Se o oficial de justiça entender por bem,
ele pode solicitar auxílio de uma força policial
para comparecer naquele local e nesse caso não
existirá nenhuma hipótese de o oficial de justiça
passar por algum risco de um ocupante descontrolado
ou algo assim.
Esse ocupante pode inclusive sair dessa desocupação sendo
levado a DHC para responder para algum crime
que ele tenha cometido contra o oficial de
justiça ou contra o auxílio de força policial
que esse oficial de justiça tenha pedido.
E aqui um ponto importante, essa notificação que
você fez antes para tentar um acordo vai
ser em vão caso o ocupante fale que
não vai sair do imóvel?
Não, essa notificação é mais um argumento que
você vai apresentar para o juiz para falar
olha eu tentei antes e ele não quis
então realmente eu preciso do poder judiciário para
que essa pessoa saia do imóvel e o
juiz vai conceder tranquilamente essa ordem para você.
Esse modelo de emissão na posse ele também
vai acontecer para o caso de terceiro leilão,
venda direta, venda online direta, licitação aberta, licitação
fechada.
Toda a desocupação que ocorra tendo em vista
o procedimento da lei 9.514, que é
a lei que regula a relação financiária, vai
ser feita dessa forma.
Não importa se foi feito em primeiro, em
segundo leilão, em um terceiro leilão que o
criador tem realizado, em venda direta, em licitação
aberta ou licitação fechada.
O procedimento é sempre o mesmo.
Primeiro você vai tentar o acordo de desocupação,
depois se você não conseguir, você vai entrar
com essa ação de emissão na posse para
que o poder judiciário determine a desocupação daquele
imóvel.
Lembrando que, como eu falei um pouco antes,
para que você possa entrar com essa ação
de emissão na posse, você necessariamente vai ter
que ter o registro do imóvel no seu
nome.
Então, não adianta você dar a entrada no
registro no cartório, como eu falei, demora em
média 30 dias e antes de o cartório
finalizar o registro, você entrar com a ação
de emissão na posse, porque o juiz vai
receber aquela ação e aquela ação não vai
estar devidamente instruída com a documentação necessária para
que ele consiga eliminar.
Qual é a definitivo registro em seu nome?
A partir do definitivo registro em seu nome,
você pode requerer ao poder judiciário que o
poder judiciário determine a desocupação daquele bem.
Sempre existe uma dúvida muito comum, que eu
já falei até no módulo 1 e vou
repetir aqui.
As pessoas sempre têm medo de...
Existe a possibilidade de eu arrematar um imóvel
em leilão e não conseguir a desocupação daquele
imóvel?
Não, essa chance não existe, desde que você
observe que aquele procedimento foi correto.
Então, se você observar que aquele procedimento foi
correto, que realmente o devedor foi constituído para
pagar dívida, que ele não pagou, que houve
a consolidação da propriedade em nome do credor,
que o credor notificou o devedor das datas
daquele leilão, você não precisa se preocupar quanto
a isso.
Uma vez respeitado aquele procedimento, o poder judiciário
deve realizar a desocupação do bem.
Não é impeditivo para isso, idade de ninguém,
nem uma pessoa muito idosa, nem uma criança.
Mas, se você não se sentir confortável para
esses casos, recorra àquilo que a gente falou
no módulo 1.
Recorra à forma de saber quem é o
ocupante daquele imóvel, recorra a informações que porteiros
de condomínio podem te passar, recorra ao site
consultface.com para fazer análise da pessoa através
do CPF dela, descobrir a idade dela e,
assim, você possa ter o máximo de segurança
que você precisar para fazer uma arrematação.
Mas, se você se sentir seguro em arrematar
um imóvel com uma pessoa muito idosa ou
com uma criança muito pequena, também não tem
nenhum impedimento quanto a isso.
Faça a arrematação, faça o procedimento e vai
ficar tudo certo.
O poder judiciário não pode impedir que o
arrematante tome posse do imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque o arrematante é um terceiro de boa
-fé.
Ele é um terceiro que entrou numa relação
para resolver um problema de uma relação.
Esse mecanismo de leilão excrediticial é um mecanismo
inteiramente previsto em lei.
Então, o poder judiciário tem que seguir a
lei e essa lei é plenamente válida.
Essa lei já foi, num passado, questionada perante
o STF.
O STF falou que não, que essa lei
é realmente constitucional, que essa lei é realmente
válida, que todos aqueles mecanismos da lei devem
ser respeitados.
Então, o judiciário deve seguir aquilo que está
na lei.
Se você arrematar, não conseguir um acordo, você
vai entregar uma ação de missão na posse
e o judiciário vai conceder a desocupação daquele
imóvel para você.
E se o imóvel estiver desocupado?
Se o imóvel estiver desocupado, você não vai
precisar mandar uma notificação para ninguém, afinal não
tem ocupante naquele imóvel e você também não
precisa fazer uma ação de missão na posse.
Isso aí seria onerar você de uma forma
desproporcional, é uma coisa que não teria por
que você fazer.
Você pagar um advogado para entrar com processo
para desocupar um imóvel que está desocupado.
Você não precisa disso.
Qual é a forma correta de você entrar
na posse de um imóvel que está desocupado?
Primeiro, você precisa ter certeza que aquele imóvel
está desocupado.
Segundo, você pode entrar diretamente na posse daquele
imóvel, você pode comparecer naquele imóvel e aí
você pode fazer um registro só para se
prevenir, para que não possa ter nenhuma ligação
futura de que aquele imóvel estava desocupado.
Como é que você pode fazer isso?
Se for um condomínio, você pode pedir que
um zelador do condomínio, síndico do condomínio ou
algum porteiro do condomínio compareça com você naquele
imóvel.
Você vai precisar de um chaveiro para abrir
a porta daquele imóvel, caso o banco não
esteja com a chave daquele imóvel e aí
você vai abrir esse imóvel, já faz aquele
mesmo procedimento que eu falei antes, já pede
para o chaveiro trocar o miolo daquela fechadura
para que só você possa ter aquela chave
daquele imóvel, você vai ter a certeza que
só você tem e aí aquelas pessoas que
estão te acompanhando vão servir como testemunha de
que não existe nenhum bem daquele devedor naquele
imóvel.
Eu faço um vídeo contra isso, né?
Estou aqui no dia tal, hora tal, na
presença do síndico, do porteiro, na presença de
qualquer outra pessoa que você possa levar, que
possa servir de testemunha e filme que aquele
imóvel está desocupado.
Se você for fazer isso sozinho, se você
não puder fazer isso com ninguém, não puder
levar ninguém para lá, se não for um
condomínio, se for uma casa de rua em
que não tenha funcionários de um condomínio para
que te acompanhe, você pode fazer isso sozinho
também.
Eu recomendo que você faça da mesma forma
um vídeo e aí eu recomendo que você
tenha algum outro celular que você possa filmar
a tela daquele celular, provando o dia e
a hora que você está entrando a primeira
vez naquele imóvel e você filme que naquele
imóvel não tem nada.
Salve esse filme em algum lugar seguro, que
você não perca o acesso a ele, você
pode mandar esse filme para o seu e
-mail e aquele vídeo vai ficar lá e
vai ser a prova de que realmente você
tomou posse daquele imóvel e aquele imóvel estava
desocupado.
Também junte qualquer tipo de recibo que você
tenha, que você realizou para fazer a desocupação
daquele imóvel.
Acabei de falar que se você não tiver
a chave do imóvel, muitas vezes o banco
não tem a chave daquele imóvel para te
passar mesmo que aquele imóvel esteja desocupado.
Um exemplo muito claro disso é o que
eu falei anteriormente, a conta da informação diz
que está ocupado, mas você em contato com
alguém, você descobriu que aquele imóvel está desocupado.
O que aconteceu nesse caso?
A pessoa descobriu que o imóvel estava indo
a leilão no diatal, não quis passar para
o processo de desocupação, preferiu sair antes daquele
imóvel ir a leilão.
Você sabe que aquele imóvel está desocupado, alguém
te confirmou, seja um porteiro de um prédio,
alguma coisa assim, você vai levar um chaveiro
naquele imóvel para que ele possa abrir a
porta daquele imóvel para você.
Esse chaveiro, você pede para ele um recibo,
uma nota fiscal do serviço que ele fez
e você vai guardar esse recibo, essa nota
fiscal comprovando que naquele diatal, em hora tal,
foi realizado o serviço do chaveiro para abrir
a porta do imóvel na rua tal.
Aí você pede para o chaveiro colocar direitinho
a data que ele compareceu, a hora que
ele compareceu e o endereço do local que
ele compareceu para fazer esse serviço.
Esses dois tipos de documento, tanto o vídeo
que você vai produzir quanto esse documento de
um chaveiro ou de algum outro profissional que
você precise chamar, vão ser mais do que
suficientes para que você possa provar caso algum
dia esse devedor te questione, que tinha alguma
coisa dele dentro daquele imóvel, vai ser a
forma idônea que você pode provar que realmente
não tinha nada do devedor daquele imóvel, que
você tomou posse porque o imóvel estava desocupado
e assim você não precisou entrar com uma
ação de emissão na posse.